okay well i'm sure you uh saw this over
the weekend everyone's talking about it
president trump announced that his
lawyer rudy giuliani
was going to hold a press conference at
the philadelphia four seasons
then later uh the president corrected
himself and said it was it four
seasons total landscaping a small
landscaping company
in philadelphia yeah everyone knows
about this story rudy giuliani did
indeed announce that president trump
will contest the election
in front of the garage door at four
seasons total landscaping
in philadelphia yeah class move
of course everyone assumed that they
actually wanted to hold the press
conference at the four seasons hotel and
that there was a mix-up
i did some research and found that a lot
of famous historical moments took place
in front of four seasons total
landscaping in philadelphia
for example it's where barack obama
announced the death of osama bin laden
yeah now i remember that it was also
where richard nixon
announced his resignation it's where fdr
gave his famous day of infamy speech
after the attack on pearl harbor and
there were also some great sports
moments too like
uh ali knocked out frasier in front of
four seasons landscaping
and as a catholic myself i'll never
forget when they announced the election
of pope benedict the first yep that was
big
the 2012 oscars were held there
fans of the royal family will also
remember that four seasons total
landscaping
is where meghan markle first showed off
her new baby
and of course we all remember it's where
they shot the series finale of friends
and that's what we did with photographs
and a computer
see you can accomplish anything if
you're relatively lazy